From a World War II film about a dressed-up corpse
to a creepy horror comedy about a satanic child,
Netflix has a whole slew of hidden gems that
are just waiting to be discovered… by you!
30 Minutes or Less is a lively action comedy
anchored by some of the strongest comic voices of
the new millennium. In the film, Jesse Eisenberg
plays Nick Davis, a nerdy pizza delivery boy.
"Tick tock."
However, one of Nick's deliveries goes haywire
when two wannabe criminals take him hostage,
attach a bomb to his chest, and force
him to rob a bank. Well aware of his
limitations and the dark absurdity of
the situation, Nick brings along Chet,
an old friend whose relationship with him
has grown strained. If Nick and Chet want
to survive their predicament, they'll have to
solve their issues and figure out how to be
pals again. Peter Bradshaw of The Guardian
had this to say about 30 Minutes or Less:
"It's entirely ridiculous,
but it gallops cheerfully along. Everything
is carried off with flair and ingenuity."
The best science-fiction tales aren't just
about unsure futures and alien worlds — they
also use new and unfamiliar environments to
point out universal truths about the human
condition. The script for Advantageous
is that kind of story. The film is set
in a technologically-advanced New York City
of tomorrow, where the divide between the
rich and the poor is more pronounced than
ever. As a result of this class struggle,
mothers will do absolutely anything to make
sure their children get an upper hand in life.
For Gwen, a wealthy cosmetic procedure salesperson
who gets fired right as her daughter enters an
expensive school, that means agreeing to be a test
subject for a painful procedure. The procedure
involves having her consciousness transferred
entirely into a new body. Complications arise,
calling into question whether or not this new
Gwen is even Gwen at all. In its review of
Advantageous, The Magazine of Fantasy and Science
Fiction called the film "quiet and affecting."
A young woman named Alice secretly
performs explicit acts as Lola_Lola,
camgirl extraordinaire. Though she's willing
to do whatever it takes to rise through the
ranks of popularity on her seedy hosting
site, Alice is able to keep an emotional
distance from her work — that is until a
dark contingent encourages her to perform
a shocking act of violence. In his review of
the film, Ty Burr of The Boston Globe wrote:
"Cam plays with both psychological horror
genre tropes and darker existential themes,
and its clear-eyed view of the drab realities
of a camgirl's life is both
refreshing and ultra-creepy."
You might be wondering what Dolemite is My Name is
doing on a list of "underrated" movies. After all,
the film was a favorite among critics and
was nominated for a few awards. But it
was also snubbed by the Academy Awards, not
receiving a single Oscar nomination. So the
film is on this list precisely because
of the snubs it received. It's a shame
the movie didn't get more recognition
because Dolemite is My Name is terrific.
Dolemite is My Name tells the story of Rudy
Ray Moore, comedian and Blaxploitation actor
known for his Dolemite movies. The movie
covers Moore's life from the period right
before he became a star all the way to the Los
Angeles premiere of his first film. Eddie Murphy,
in a comeback of sorts, does
an outstanding job as Moore.
"Dolemite is my name! And
rappin' and tappin' is my game."
Not only is Murphy great as Moore but his co-stars
are amazing, too. Wesley Snipes is wonderful
playing the director of "Dolemite," while Da'Vine
Joy Randolph is tremendous as Lady Reed, Moore's
long-time friend and confidant. The costumes,
by Oscar-winning designer Ruth E. Carter,
are also a stand out in this well-made comedy.
A coming-of-age story about people just trying to
find their place in the world, Dumplin' boasts
a cast led by comedy legend Jennifer Aniston
and charismatic star-on-the-rise Danielle
Macdonald. The latter plays Willowdean
Dickson. She prefers to be called Will, but her
mother insists on referring to her as Dumplin'.
A supremely confident and witty teenager,
Dumplin' stands up for herself against bullies
who criticize her for her weight. Standing
up to her mother, however, is a lot harder.
So what better way to establish herself than
competing in her mother's beloved Miss Teen
Bluebonnet Pageant? What initially begins as
a protest against pageants and her mother,
soon becomes a celebration of all types
of beauty, thus prompting other overlooked
misfits to join Dumplin'. In her review of
the film, Elizabeth Weitzman of TheWrap wrote:
"This is a generous movie, and an
unrepentant fantasy at that, so it's
hard not to meet it with open heartedness."
The Netflix series The Last Kingdom is a
historical drama about King Alfred the Great of
what would become England. The show blends actual
events from the 9th century with fiction to tell
the story of how kingdoms were brought together
to form a united England. At the start, the
land has been captured by the invading Vikings,
with only King Alfred and his Kingdom of
Wessex standing in the way to total domination.
"Come and fight! Why are you afraid?"
The Last Kingdom tells the
story of Uhtred of Bebbanburg,
a noble Saxon who gets kidnapped as
a slave and then raised by the Danes.
Uhtred is conflicted — to whom does he
pledge his allegiance? So he's ultimately
forced to choose between the people that
raised him and the land of his birth.
The series has everything you'd want in
a historical drama covering this time
period — brutal fighting, great characters, an
intriguing story, loads of death, and gorgeous
cinematography. So if you're in the market for
a show full of English accents and good old
fashioned swordplay, The Last Kingdom is for you.
An unassuming movie but one speckled with action,
tension, and agonizing personal drama, Leave No
Trace is about the unbreakable bond between a
parent and child. Will is an Iraq War veteran
suffering from post-traumatic stress disorder.
Will's PTSD is so severe that he's become deeply
uncomfortable interacting with people. So he
raises his teenage daughter Tom in vast forested
parks outside of Portland. After authorities find
them and set them up with a home on a Christmas
tree farm, Tom enjoys the stability. She also
likes being around other kids. But when Will makes
them leave again, Tom is forced to choose between
her family and her own path. In his review of
the film, David Stratton of The Australian wrote:
"Leave No Trace is a small film
but a quietly memorable one."
Little Evil is a horror-comedy about an
eager-to-please guy who marries a woman who
has a son from a previous marriage. He's desperate
to connect with the inscrutable little guy so that
the three of them can all come together as a
happy, blended family. That's a difficult task,
as the kid is actually the spawn of Satan.
Needless to say, he's not afraid to unleash pure
evil and terror on his well-meaning new stepdad.
Amanda Sink of The Hollywood Outsider wrote:
"'Little Evil' is '[The] Omen'
by way of 'Shaun of the Dead.'"
Maniac is hard to categorize. It's
a darkly comic, often surreal,
and lightly dystopian miniseries set
in a future world where gadgetry and
pharmaceuticals have rapidly progressed. In the
series, Annie, who's desperate and guilt-ridden,
and Owen, who's the troubled black sheep
of a rich family, lockdown for a heavily
controlled psychological drug trial. The trial is
operated by the eccentric Dr. James K. Mantleray,
who is literally and explicitly in love with
machinery. He also lives in the shadow of
his mother, Dr. Greta Mantleray, a popular
pop psychologist and best-selling author.
The series also explores
the minds of Owen and Annie,
who live out their deepest fears
and insecurities in disparate ways,
such as an exotic animal heist and a
Lord of the Rings-esque fantasy. Not
only dazzling and challenging, Maniac manages to
be "vibrant, ridiculous, and, to varying degrees,
moving," according to Willa Paskin of Slate.
Operation Mincemeat tells a fascinating and
gripping but little-known World War II
story, one so filled with audacious and
foolhardy participants that it's hard
to believe it's real. Set in 1943,
the Allied forces plan to stop Hitler's conquest
of Europe with a multi-pronged attack on Sicily,
a troubling option because it would ensure
mass casualties on both sides. And so, two
elite British intelligence officers come up with
a bizarre scheme, known as "Operation Mincemeat."
"Our other deception plans are
strategies designed to confuse the enemy,
throw him off balance. Mincemeat, on
the other hand, is an outright lie."
With plenty of help from higher-ups and the
rank-and-file, they dress up an abandoned corpse
in a Royal Marines uniform and plant evidence
of a false Allied invasion on it. From there,
the intelligence officers wait for the Axis
forces to discover the dressed-up corpse and
act accordingly on the misinformation. In his
rave of the film, Jake Wilson of The Age wrote:
"'Operation Mincemeat' is a genuine
surprise package — it prompts nostalgia,
if not for the war, then for an almost equally
distant era of skillfully crafted entertainment."
After expelling Belgian colonialists in 1960,
the Congo declared independence. So in 1961,
the United Nations arrived to help support the
newly formed government. U.N. peacekeeping troops
soon got caught up in a civil war between
the Democratic Republic of the Congo and
the natural resource-heavy secessionist
state of Katanga. The Siege of Jadotville
tells of a little-known moment in this seven-day
conflict, in which 3,000 mercenaries working for
mining companies in Katanga attacked the
150 Irish troops serving under the U.N.
Led by commandant Pat Quinlan, the
defense held its ground, pushing
back the thousands of attackers while waiting for
reinforcements to arrive. The film is a harrowing,
high-stakes drama, loaded with military action and
almost unbelievable acts of courage and tactical
brilliance. If you're a fan of war movies,
The Siege of Jadotville is not to be missed.
The fear of turning into one's parents as
they settle into adulthood is an extremely
common worry — it's also the basis for the
psychological-supernatural horror film Umma.
Amanda and her teenage daughter Chrissy
enjoy an idyllic existence on their farm,
hanging out and tending to bees. However,
everything changes when the remains of Amanda's
mother arrive from Korea. Umma wasn't a good mom —
she was cruel and abusive — and it was the reason
for a long estrangement. But what remains
of her bodily form literally haunts Amanda,
as she quickly evolves into her mother at her
most monstrous and horrific. While critics found
the film to be uneven, Umma is still worth
a watch. The film is original and quirky
while its unpredictable plot and character
choices subvert many horror movie cliches.